c'est un peu ça que vous qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est que ces concepts et ses
mots d'extrême droite qui ont été amenés
dans le débat on a un peu l'impression
finalement que comment dire que que leur
elle n'a pas eu lieu qui a pas eu
d'événements finalement que tout est
fini par faire de discours
or effectivement à ce qui s'est passé
aussi c'est qu'il ya eu des événements
qui ont fait que les lignes ont bougé et
idéologique
il ya eu par exemple on septembre il ya
eu les attentats de charlie hebdo qui
ont porté la question de l'islamisme
il ya eu plusieurs vagues migratoires
ont posé la question de l'immigration
il ya eu une crise économique qui a posé
la question de la modélisation de des
déséquilibres de l'harmonisation du
retour de l'état nation ces événements
ont eu lieu et ont fait bouger les
lignes idéologiques c'est pas simplement
des discours qui ont introduit une
confusion
en fait je j'ai l'impression que
finalement vous décrivez un monde comme
si les événements n'avaient pas eu lieu
qu'il n'y avait que des discours or je
pense qu'il ya quand même des événements
et qu'il fait conclut une partie de la
gauche par exemple qui a été décrite par
daniel linda dans les néo réactionnaires
qui n'a cessé depuis fait a fait un peu
de sport d'un jean d'un manteau
notamment sur la question du
multiculturalisme
de deux les deux de la question de
l'islamisme et caetera et a évolué si
ces questions là je pense à des gens
comme jacques julliard maintient que
côte que pascal bruckner et et est ce
que est ce que c'est ce qu'ils font a
forcément interprété ça sur la porte
d'une dérive
moi je lis plutôt comme une femme d'âge
en un même taux de façon réelle
[Musique]
il